i still hate intros my hero academia
season 4 part 2
episode 13. we hop back a bit where the
girls are fighting with a villain named
rikiya
he is draining their life force taking
nasui and ochako out of the fight toga
shows up disguised as midoriya
saying that the others are in danger and
need help this somehow gets them back
into the fight and they end up smashing
through the street winding up where the
real midoriya is
the league villains are hoping to kidnap
aries since she is the core of the
yakuza operation
when the fighting starts up again we get
a flashback of arie when she was a
little girl
she had accidentally used her power on
her father which made him disappear her
mother said that she was cursed and
didn't want her so her grandfather and
the leader of the haasekai took her in
he had asked overhaul to look after her
and also to find out what her ability
is well studying her he found out that
her quirk actually gives her the ability
to rewind which she's never
actually told her back to the present
where era uses her power to rewind
overhaul's body to before he had
absorbed nematode bringing him back
she comes to the realization that the
heroes will keep coming for her until
she is saved so for the first time she
trusts them and tries to get to midoriya
midoriya had jumped to get to arie who
is being taken away by
overhaul he manages to get to her and
then uses all of his power to launch
them both into the air
this is confusing to him though because
when he did this he used 100 percent of
one for all to ensure airy safety
meanwhile overhaul needs a new boost in
power since his fusion with nematode was
cancelled out so this time he absorbs
rakia
we learned that aries ability had
rewound midoriya's body to before he was
injured but the problem is that she
doesn't know how to shut it off
this means that his body's going to keep
on rewinding until it's nothing which is
what happened to her father
overhaul catches up to them again but
this time he's in his final boss form
he figures with her quirk constantly
activated he can just keep on destroying
his body and she'll be able to heal him
letting him fight at a constant 100
percent the power allows him to do some
serious damage to overhaul with just
one hit
well overhaul is flying through the air
after the shot we get a flashback of him
telling the boss about his plan
he wanted to create bullets to
deactivate hero's quirks and sell them
to the villains
on the other hand he also wanted to
create a serum to sell to the heroes
creating a monopoly on both sides that
would make the shiehasakai
rulers of the underground and the boss
was like [ __ ] that this forces him to
make the boss sick so he can't interfere
and he plans on restoring him back to
health once his plan is complete
back on up to the present where midoriya
lands a flurry of punches and defeats
overhaul without any problems
this also proves that ni's vision of the
future can be
changed meaning that all might can still
be saved yeah episode 14.
tamaki manages to get to cronus stasis
and apprehends him just before he kills
a racer head
when overhaul takes one last swing at
midoriya aery causes his body to rewind
to before he absorbed rakia
after that midoriya is still being
rewound by her power until a racerhead
steps in to nullify it all in all the
raid was a success
and the haazikai are arrested but the
league of villains members got away
shortly after the fight the league of
villains attacks the convoy escorting
overhaul to the hospital
even though the useless side character
snatch is with the convoy he is defeated
by mr compress
they get to overhaul and as punishment
for him defying them they destroy both
of his arms meaning that he can no
longer use his quirk for some reason the
four remaining quirk destroying bullets
were being transported with him also so
now the league of villains has that too
hey so what do you guys think we should
do with these four bullets that
threatens the stability of our entire
society i know let's transport an
ambulance with the main antagonist who
made them oh good idea what about
security one useless side character good
thinking
we see that everybody survived the
ordeal and naidi is in rough condition
he gets visited by all my and together
it gets all emotional
and he dies episode 15. detective
sukuchi and gran torino heads into the
mountains because there have been
sightings of kurogeri there
they find and subdue him but turns out
the reason he was out there is because
he was meeting with someone we then meet
giganto machia who was a faithful
servant to all for one midoriya goes to
check up bontogda who seems to be in
high spirits considering he just watched
his mentor die and lost his powers
his upbeat attitude makes midoriya
realize why night i was hoping that he
would inherit one for all so he asks him
what he would say if he could give his
powers to him together refuses though
saying that it would only cause midoriya
problems and it's not like midoriya did
a bad job he is hoping that once arie
learns to control her power
then maybe she can rewind his body to
when he still had his work the next day
all might and present mike meet up with
todoroki and bakugou for their
provisional license training course
eraserhead was supposed to be the one
meeting with them but he's busy helping
airy we then learned that gran torino
had managed to capture kurogeri but
giganto machia made a mess of things and
managed to get away
back over to the training course where
endeavour is there also
and wants to talk with all might
meanwhile we see that some of the
shiketsu high school students from the
previous season are going to be
participating in the course also
episode 16. dude rookie bakago kami and
inasa
are given a task to find a way to deal
with some unruly kids
well that's going on all my and endeavor
look on from the stands and have their
talk
and never seems to be struggling with
filling all my shoes as the number one
hero
and it's weighing on his mental oh my
just gives him some generic advice
saying that you should just focus on the
hero you want to be
instead of trying to replace him anyways
back to the other filler content the
little [ __ ] aren't listening so
nobody knows what to do this takes the
[ __ ] scenic route but eventually
winds its way around to the kids wanting
to fight the students in the last scene
episode 17. all the kids try attacking
the students but obviously their attacks
are less ineffective
because they can't really attack them
back they use their powers to create a
nice slide for the kids to play
this wins the kids over so they pass the
test afterwards endeavour talks with
todoroki who still
isn't really his biggest fan endeavour
promises him that he's gonna try and be
a better hero and father to become
somebody that todoroki can be proud of
hinasa originally hated endeavor also
but after hearing this he kind of wins
him over
after the incident the work study
program is put on hold for all of the
students
night eyes sidekick centipeder took over
nidai's agency and is working with
bubble girl they're also eagerly
awaiting the return of together if he
ever gets his powers back
harry had to regain consciousness but
can't have any visitors due to the
instability of her powers
the horn on her head that powers her
rewind quirk began to shrink and it's
now just a bump we then get some more
filler content on how ao yelman tries to
raise midori spirits but it's just kind
of creepy while doing it the sentiment
is nice though and the two become closer
friends at the end of it
episode 18. filler content continues
where everybody tries to figure out what
they're gonna do for their school
festival they want to have jiro perform
live music and have a dance party for
their class but jiro is too shy and
doesn't want him they convinced her to
do it or whatever and then we learned
that ever since arie had woken up she
has only had one request
and that's to see midoriya and together
so they make an exception to the no
visitor role
when they go to see her she's still in a
dark place and feels guilty about toga
to losing his powers
that's when they get the idea to have
her attend the ua festival in hopes of
raising her spirits
we then hop on over to the chief of
police kenji as they investigate a
villain by the name of gentle criminal
he is an internet celebrity that posts
videos of himself committing crimes
there's a new video of him robbing a
store and then defeating a group of
heroes that try to stop him
his partner in crime and camera chick is
the little girl named la brava
they aren't getting enough exposure on
their videos wonder what that's like so
they plan to do something big to get
their name out there
episode 19. gentle criminal only targets
people or establishments that behave in
a quote un-gentlemanly way so he's a
scuff vigilante
thief back to class 1a who set their
roles for the festival with the band
team effects team
and dance team after that midoriya meets
with all might to express his concern
that even when he was fighting overhaul
at 20
he still wasn't strong enough all might
takes him outside for a lesson where
midoriya has an epiphany he decides to
control a percentage of one body part
and raise it to 20
for a split second which will cause a
focused blast the air pressure creates a
ranged attack that's strong enough to
knock down a tree and adds to his
overall arsenal
and in the last scene we see that arie
had arrived at ua high school
episode 20. arie was allowed to go to
the campus ahead of time to avoid any
unnecessary stresses and explore a bit
she goes around the campus with midoriya
and together visiting all the side
characters that are preparing for the
festival
when they talk to the principal we see a
flashback of the police wanting to
cancel the event because of the recent
events with villains
midnight tells him that if there's any
alarm even a false one the festival will
be shut down
they had also implemented some extra
security measures in the form of hound
dog who will be patrolling
around the campus later on while out
practicing his new move hatsume ends up
running into them
apparently midoriya had asked her to
design a new glove for his wind pressure
move and she tells him that it's almost
done
after that while online midoriya
accidentally clicks onto
one of gentle criminals videos then we
hop on over to gentle who is hoping to
infiltrate the festival to give the
heroes a wake-up call and make them see
that it's too dangerous for them to be
having events like this
episode 21 midoriya is supposed to hold
aoyama up so he can be a human disco
ball for the performance but the rope
that they're gonna use is getting a
little worn out
jump ahead to the morning of the
festival where hatsume finds midoriya
and delivers his new gloves
after that he goes to the convenience
store to get some new rope for the
performance
while he's out he ends up running into
gentle criminal and while talking he
recognizes his voice from the video he
had watched midoriya wants to prevent
any alarms from being sound so that eric
can enjoy the festival and all their
hard work won't go to waste they both
get into a fight where we learn that
gentle squirk is elasticity and can be
applied to anything that he touches even
the air this turns out to be a good
opportunity for midoriya to practice his
new air pressure
in the attacks couple of scenes me doria
is forced to ensure that a man isn't
crushed by a beam which buys gentle
enough time to start making his way
towards the school
episode 22. as they approach the school
midoriya catches up to them and uses his
gloves to apprehend them this prompts a
flashback of la brava being bullied in
school and coming across
gentle he was kind to her or whatever
and that's why she's so devoted to
helping him lubrava's quirk is
love when she says that she loves
somebody it gives them a boost to their
power
and the deeper her love the stronger
they get she uses this to give
gentle enough power to fight back
against midoriya prompting another
flashback this time we see the young
gentle criminal who dreamed of being a
hero but can never pass the test
while trying to save a man he obstructs
a hero by mistake and the man is
severely wounded
after that he felt like he was being
forgotten so he instead decided to be a
villain midoriya manages to restrain him
again as
hound dog and ectoplasm are closing in
on their position wanting to protect la
brava gentle uses the last of his
strength to knock midoriya away and then
turns himself
into the heroes episode 23. found dog
takes gentle into custody and escorts
him to the police station along with la
brava
meanwhile midoriya gets back just in
time for his part in the festival the
concert is a huge hit with the students
and for the first time they get arie to
smile and have a good time the rest of
it is pretty filler-esque with them
going around the rest of the festival
when it's over aries take him back to
the hospital getting a candy apple as a
parting gift from midoriya
episode 24. everybody gets the news that
arie is gonna be living at ua her horn
was getting bigger again so they don't
want to put her into an orphanage
they figure this is the best alternative
so she can figure out how to control her
power
class 1a then gets a visit from the wild
wild pussycats and coda that's pretty
filleresque and then we hop on over to
the first hero billboard chart since all
might have retired and everybody is
eager to see who the most popular heroes
are
during the ceremony we meet the top 10
heroes with endeavour being number one
we also meet the number two hero in
hawks who decides to stir things up a
bit with his speech
afterwards endeavour isn't too happy
with him but then he mentions that he is
hoping to work together with endeavour
hux says that there's been some new
sightings of no moose in his hometown
we then hop on over to dobby who seems
to have a new friend called
high-end but anyways back to the heroes
while out walking with hawks endeavour
realizes how charismatic and
approachable he is to everybody
on the other hand everybody is
intimidated by endeavor and afraid to
talk to him he tries to be friendly
which doesn't go over so well but it's
obvious he's making an effort to be a
better hero
while eating hawks speculates that
somebody is spreading stories about
these
no moves all over the country we also
get a brief mention of a villain
biography that could be inspiring new
criminals
hawks requests that endeavor investigate
these rumors and if it turns out to be
nothing then to prove that they're not
valid
in the last couple of scenes their talk
gets interrupted by high-end who came
looking for a fight
episode 25. we get a quick scene of
todoroki's mom visiting with her
daughter and son
in fiumi and natsuo natsu is mad at
endeavor for not taking any
responsibility for how badly he had
treated the family rey doesn't think
that's necessarily the case because he
did come by a couple of different times
to drop off her favorite flowers
even though she never talked to him she
believes that he is trying to make
things right in his own way but anyways
back to the fight where endeavour
injures high-end revealing that he has
regeneration powers healing him back to
new
this is also the first no move that they
had come across that can actually talk
during fighting we learn that hawk's
ability allows him to control his
feathers and he uses this to get by
standards to safety from the collapsing
building
other no-name heroes try to intervene
and help in the fight but they get
intercepted by
white nomus who keep them busy it's then
revealed that endeavour's weakness is
that after too much fighting he starts
to overheat and his body begins to
deteriorate he claims that this is the
reason he was so hard on his family
while they were growing up
at the risk of damaging himself he uses
one more massive attack called
prominence burn in hopes of killing
high-end before his regeneration can
kick
in this almost works but high end had
tore off its own head and thrown it away
from the flames in order to survive
high and then retaliates and endeavour
is severely wounded but despite that he
keeps fighting back
we see everybody watching the fight
unfold including todoroki and his
siblings
hux catches up to the fight and uses his
feathers to launch
endeavor and high end into the air to
avoid any collateral
this is endeavour's q to let loose
another prominence burn which can't be
dodged this time since he has a hold up
high end
the attack doesn't have to finish the
fight with endeavour barely being able
to stand afterwards
after the credits we see midoriya having
a cryptic dream of his predecessors and
he hears a voice saying he is the ninth
i'm going to be doing the future seasons
and you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the my hero academia
recaps in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is outros